kristin this is so exciting getting to
talk to you like everybody else i love
your voice so this album is so good
listen happiness is christmas but it's
also
love so i wanted to say congratulations
on your engagement thank you i can't
believe it happened look look i'm
selling my ring
he did good
he did very well that is gorgeous what
was your reaction when you first saw the
ring
well we had seen we kind of went looking
secretly it was the first one we saw and
we both went i like that and it's one of
a kind and
my
fingers are three and a half and so they
had to size it down but i didn't know
when it was coming and i'm just so
i feel very blessed very thankful you
know it covered either brought people
together or united people and it brought
us together oh my did you know when you
first met him or was this something that
gradually became obvious
the first time i met him was at my
niece's wedding he was playing in the in
the band that they had hired
and i thought he was cute and we were
both dating other people the second
summer he played for my nephew's wedding
and we were both single and that's when
we kind of
clicked
that's like the universe bringing you
together twice i know
i can't believe it
is this happening
no i was like okay i need to pay
attention here yeah
ah i love hearing that well
congratulations that's so exciting i
feel like so much is going on in your
life right now it was also great to see
you on the voice as a mentor for ariana
grande's
team what was that like working with her
and teaming up with her
you know i teach a lot and
what i was most proud of was watching
somebody that i have mentored
become the mentor
yeah i didn't have to i didn't have to
say much because she was
right on the money
and i was so proud of her
i just added what little things here and
there but mainly for me the moment was
personally watching her become the
teacher
and she's got a great team and i've
known her since she was 10.
so
you know it's a long relationship and
i'm so proud of her and i think she's a
great addition to the show
oh i do too she is such a natural you
just can't not watch her
i'm always waiting to see what she's
going to say
me too
this must be such a full circle moment
for you then because we know that ariana
grande has been cast as glinda in the
film version of wicked of course a role
that you originated on stage
what was that like hearing that
i have been i have been so i couldn't be
more proud if if it were as if my own
kid
you know and lots of friends of mine
that i love
not lots a couple that i adore were also
being considered for different parts in
glenda as well and i was
thinking about it and i just literally
gave it up to the universe obviously i
had nothing to do with it john chu
picked you know these wonderful
actresses but i just was there to hold
her hand through the process
and
when it happened we cried
and i know
the role is in the right hands
oh my goodness i i honestly had no idea
you had such history that is so
fantastic i love hearing that well here
we were doing the voice yeah and she's
going through the audition process
and you know
it looks like i already knew right doing
the voice but i we didn't know we just
hoped we just she was going through the
process
and then look what happened
well if you were asked would you make a
cameo in the film
of course if if i was asked of course i
would i would expect that you know if
that would be uh and dina and i both
but you know
i just feel like it's their time
and
i'll be there to hold their hand they
don't need me to do that but i will
and i think the casting of cynthia is
genius
as elphaba i think she's going to blow
the roof off the place i think they both
and really what i really want to say is
i'm so glad they chose the director they
chose because john knows what he's doing
i'm so excited to see what he's got up
his sleeve